[Music]
hey there river babes
I'm your host Liana Galera and welcome
to our live Sweetwater secrets preview
show for episode 319 chapter 54 here's
the Reaper now I'm back with your three
clues with what you need to know about
this week's episode because it was in
high demand because I didn't do it last
week plus we're gonna do our live Q&A
session so start sending me your biggest
questions and comments and I'll get to
them at the end of the show we're
starting to get in so many Sidney
Bennett misery see Michael clap [ __ ] I
see you I'm getting to you but first
let's dive into your kisses kisses
comments and series from our Sweetwater
secrets after-show for episode 318
kicking us off you need Karen eek
welcome back girl commented hisses to
Alice were saying that Betty scares her
Polly made you join a cult and literally
almost killed you
drowning but yeah sure Betty's more
terrifying one loving the sarcasm there
girl and Carly Rock added the only
reason why Betty has anger issues is
because she was pressured to be perfect
all the time and bury her true emotions
it was like that in season 1 so Alice
shouldn't blame Betty or Hal for Betty's
issues I completely agree Carly and it
seems like Carlotta's gherkin is also on
the same wavelength of hash tag team
buddy because she wrote kisses to
Jughead for not letting Betty bury her
nails in her palms
I loved how he uncurled them while he
also touching her while also touching
her back I didn't even notice that in
the episode that is so sweet
I love bug head I need more I'm a broken
record but it's true
next up Gweneth Edwards posted kisses to
the best line of the episode delivered
by Miss Tony topes quote [ __ ] I love
her and she loves me ah it was so good
but you know what hasn't been good is
watching Tony's heart get yo-yoed around
every other episode and Isabella agrees
with me she posted huge kisses to my
sweet poor Tony for always being there
for Cheryl I feel so bad for her so for
some reason our baby deserves better
also kisses
to Betty and Tony's newborn friendship
what do you think Shoni fans are you
getting exasperated by everything Cheryl
is putting Tony through tell me right
now
and lastly lonely person all I hope
you're not lonely welcome to Sweetwater
commented kisses to fred / luke for just
being in the episodes and having the
best lines r.i.p yes we will all be
getting eternal kisses to Fred Andrews /
Luke Perry especially this week because
episode 319 is the last episode that
we'll be seeing him you know Riverdale
showrunner Roberto aguirre-sacasa
revealed on social media quote this
week's Riverdale is the last episode
Luke filmed as always Fred is imparting
words of wisdom to Archie a beautiful
true moment between a father and his son
wish these scenes could go on forever
now I know we all wish that too but like
Roberto said Luke's last scene is a
touching moment between Fred and Archie
and I think you're all gonna love it now
while we're looking ahead to this week's
episode let's see more of what we can
expect with a quick peek at the promo
for 319 we play we can get jellybean
back at the battle begin
he's setting me up to take the fall
wants us took a minute Robert kill you
right here there will be a reckoning
now do you see why I need to get out of
this town
yeah Josie and uh save JB seriously what
the heck we just got her can we please
save her no it's been a while since I
gifted you all with my three clues about
the episodes so let's just dive right
into those okay number one they say that
parting is such sweet sorrow but what
did they say about saving about saying
goodbye to three yeah number two what
this episode lacks in romance it makes
up for in adrenaline and betrayal and
number three I'm not gonna say anything
about my favorite twist of the week I'm
just gonna let Chad Michael Murray leave
a little tease for you instead I feel
like when you're looking at the farm
Evelyn is the bad cop and Edgar gets to
be the good cop would you agree with
that I mean I think there's always good
cop bad cop when you have a scenario
like this right okay thank you I would
say that Evelyn understands the mission
and Evelyn is gonna do her job to make
sure that the missions accomplished as
you guys know I've been frustrated by a
lot of the storylines this year in
Riverdale but episode 319 has something
that I completely did not see coming at
all and I've got to give it up to the
Riverdale riders for this one now as
always you'll need to tune in to our
seat letter after show for 3:19 to know
what on earth I'm talking about but
let's just say that I'm especially
excited to read your hisses and kisses
this week and now let's switch over to
your live comments and questions cuz you
guys are coming in full force today I'm
so excited to see you let's kick it off
Sidney Bennett says I'm kind of hoping
the farm has something to do with the
chilling Adventures of Sabrina but where
does that leave Betty does she just stay
with Jughead
I feel like chilling Adventures of
Sabrina's got its own problems going on
right now I don't know if you guys have
seen it but spoiler alert that kind of
dealing with the fact that Sabrina is
now going to hell to get her boyfriend
back sorry if that's a spoiler but I
don't think the farm has anything to do
with chilling Adventures of Sabrina I
know that Roberto is still working on
his crossover but I'm not quite sure
what that's gonna be fingers crossed it
happens in the next part of Sabrina / to
the next season
Riverdale but yes I'm waiting for that
as well
misery see I was ready to follow Edgar
anywhere until he got Sheryl and took
her from Tony and now I want to burn
down the farm fair point fair point show
any fans honestly I completely
understand why Cheryl got drawn into the
farm she loved her brother so much and
Edgar is very persuasive and we all know
that by now
but yes like I said earlier I'm getting
a little tired of Tony's heart getting
yo-yoed around I think she deserves
better so Who am I
Michael clap it says I want the farm to
be dealt with and put down even if that
means we only unbraid wash Cheryl and
between the three of them Cheryl buddy
and Tony yeah
I'm more I'm more interested in the farm
than I have been of the whole gargoyle
King storyline so I'm enjoying it it
gets crazy in tonight's episode so as
frustrating as the farm is I'm glad that
it's something that I'm excited to watch
it's not Hyrum Lodge huh
see gaming show Tony and Betty save
Cheryl fangs and Kevin please yes please
save Kevin and while you're at it give
him the storyline he's just back there
and white smiling he looks amazing but
come on I'm getting tired of this okay
CJ brown says I'm still trying to figure
out why fangs is in the farm to begin
with to be this Kevin I don't know
where's sweet pea
get him sweet pea Samantha Reed I
seriously don't why I seriously don't
know why nobody has talked about the
cute bug head scene from the last
episode it was the first scene in a
while when they were in bed I love bug
head and I think you all agree in the
fact that we needed more this season
it's been good that they've all been
kind of going off on their different
storylines Betty's had a lot going on
with the fact that her mother's now
brainwashed in an occult or the same
thing with the whole rest of her family
and her best friends but jugheads now
dealing with the fact that his mother's
the new drug queen of Riverdale it's
just a lot but at least they're strong
at least they're not broken up right now
they want to know so this is like a
general comment for all you guys they
want to know if we get more Shoni and
Jughead this season I would hope so
tonight is not so much heavy on the
romance it's more on the plot twist but
you
next week is prom night so I think we I
think we'll be good
Frank narf wants to know will there be
more Kevin and things in this episode if
you blink you might miss him
let's see Sheila girls 0 3 3 1 hope I
said that ok says hisses that Luke died
and now they've run out of episodes with
him but I cried last week when I saw him
love you and I need more Shoni we all
need more Shoni but we all need any more
Luke - you guys are gonna love the brief
scene that he's in tonight it's gonna be
really sad to say goodbye to him but we
will be paying tribute to him again in
the after show so we all love Luke and
he'll have eternal kisses from us let's
see Arielle lampooned says what if
cheryl is seeing an actual version of
Jason I mean what if Jason wasn't her
actual twin but Jason had a twin brother
and Penelope turned him to the quite
sisters of mercy and the farm took him
wow that's a good twist and a really
complicated storyline to follow and I
don't think we're gonna get that but I
like where your head's at and I think
that that would be an awesome twist we
haven't had a good twist in a while but
we're getting one tonight so get excited
Rathlin Jordan said I was mad that Kurt
and Ricky dragged JB into this same and
didn't she look so much younger last
week when she was wearing those little
elf ears she looked so cute we need to
protect JB at all costs plus I needed to
have more JB and Betty scenes because
this is crazy at this point
Maddie love are we going to see Polly's
babies again yes we are they have a very
key role in tonight's episode and I'm
going to be talking about this in the
after show but apparently they don't age
there's some kind of like bewitching
spell on them where they are just babies
for years let him grow up dog or Dodge
lover - 137 hizouse - Betty I know right
but I have a reason because after
everything she's done for other people
she thinks she is a monster yeah Betty's
really hard on herself and I think that
in her fight to do a good job she's her
own worst enemy
I think she needs to lighten up on
herself but luckily she's got Jughead
who's there to be there for her and do
that I'm CJ brown Leon do you think Tony
will be able to save Cheryl and yay for
the vixens being back are the vixens
back
where are the pretty poisons I have no
idea anymore or the gargoyles still a
thing are the surface even together what
is happening what is happening you guys
are crushing all these comments right
now there's so many of us unless we've
ever had
elegant blogs by Maddy welcome back I
like it blogs by Maddy Chad Michael
Murray loved your comment last week said
barchi information is higher I'm going
to talk to Elio for VAR Chee we do have
Hiram in this episode we do have Elio in
this episode the conversation of Archie
does come up I will just leave you with
that Lauren with Abby emoji and a yellow
heart says I'm feeling Hal escapes
prison and I hope Betty doesn't help him
I don't know how I feel about how
anymore like I never thought I'd be like
I missed the black hood because in
season 2 I was like I'm so tired of the
black hood but at this point sup he'll
Alyssa Harrington says I need Kevin back
agreed
Natalie Ortega and your opinion do you
think Hal or Alice has been Abed air has
been a better parent to Betty this
season that's a mouthful oh my god well
on the one hand you've got a serial
killer murder of a father and on the
other hand you've got a brainwashed
delusional mother who thinks that she's
seeing her dead son I'm gonna say it's a
push because I think that the emotional
torment that they've both inflicted onto
Betty I don't even know how she's still
standing
God loved her and her bobby pins okay
they all want more of the Kevins
storyline so do i I can't even tell you
how frustrated I am that that you have
Casey caught in the show who is
sensational has a voice like an angel
and is so nice to look at and is a great
human being and you do not give him more
than just walking in slow motion and
white behind everyone else sorry guys
it's the end of the season getting
really exasperated in a little salty you
already know it's Kayla said hopefully
Alice gets it in her head that Betty is
not the enemy and goes back home I feel
like at this point Alice is beyond
if she wouldn't listen to Betty's
brainwashing session down in the sex
bunker then I'm not quite sure what's
gonna happen now I think that she's
fully ingratiated into the farms grasp
and that's that's just what it is
CJ Brown am I the only one who's
wondering where the vixens were and how
they got back after being missing for
ten episodes I think what was the last
time we actually saw the vixens perform
was it in the first or second episode
when they did jailhouse rock I think
we've established that in season 3 that
school events just do not matter anymore
and we have no idea what's going on with
the vixens is Josie still in them is
Tony still on them what's going on I
have no idea but perhaps to Josie for
saying in the promo for this week's
episode now do you see why I need to get
the hell out of this town like she's the
only one who's sane at this moment I
miss our quiet little Riverdale um let's
see Tesla canta says Jughead needs to
tell FP about GLaDOS on the ASAP
honestly he needs to stop thinking he
has control that's fair secrets will be
revealed in tonight's episode during our
quest to save JB and some some big
repercussions are coming to the Jones
family so take that teyla Bernstein what
will happen to Fred in the upcoming
episodes also need more bug-head and
love Sweetwater secrets oh sorry it's
Talia sorry Talia thank you so much for
liking Sweetwater secrets I adore you
guys as for how they are going to
address Fred's upcoming storyline I'm
going to be totally honest with you guys
I have no idea what they're going to do
with the rest of Fred's arc we've
already seen that his life has been
hanging in the balance in previous
episodes when he got shot by the black
hood and all this it'll be really
interesting to see if they answer that
question this year if they choose to
address it at the beginning of season 4
all I know is that we are all gonna miss
Fred Andrews he was the one true great
parent of Riverdale and now they're just
left with a whole bunch of crazies but
love Luke love Fred not sure what
they're gonna do yet but I'll keep you
posted and I'm looking to
those answers for you guys from Roberto
very soon the diamond squid very unique
says what if jug GLaDOS an FP robbed
pops while Josie's in there she leaves
Riverdale and breaks up with Archie so
he and Veronica get back together that
is quite a journey I think it's very
clear that Josie has been exasperated
with Riverdale all season she doesn't
have the Pussycats anymore she was kind
of going back and forth with Sweet Pea
she's with Archie but it doesn't feel
quite right you're gonna really see
Josie go through a big growth in
tonight's episode and make a big
decision and we all know that she's tied
to the Katy Keane pilot which takes
place in New York so this is a natural
journey for that but it's still it's a
great episode and all my goodness
Ashleigh Marie's voice in this episode
unreal we don't deserve her
Alyssa Harrington kisses to Tony for
telling Betty she's not a monster I know
right I really enjoyed the Tony and
Betty connection that they had in last
week's episode they've always been
friendly but it's been really nice to
see them team up and I really hope that
it continues bug head shippers going
cray right now hi bug head shippers I
was about to call you buggies still like
it um Dawn of the Dead hisses to Alice
she has the nerve to say she's scared of
Betty but has done terrible things to
her look I think we've all established
that Alice's freaking nuts so at this
point she's just gonna say whatever it
is to make her situation look bad and
stay with the farm so I don't even know
anymore Arielle lampang commented again
the Dixons must have been drugged while
they while they were under medical care
I mean only hiram had access while we're
talking about like missing people
where's um oh my gosh I'm totally
blanking on her name where's the girl
that was there in the beginning of the
season and now I'm totally forgetting
her name um she was on stranger things
you guys help me right now where is she
she's been gone for so long that I
totally forgot about her name okay you
tell me and then we'll come back to it
um Kate Dunbar hisses - the way Alice
embraced Evelyn like a real daughter
since when have they been so close how
close are they since Alice and Edgar are
a thing honestly I don't even know like
but the fact that she embraced Evelyn
like that was just weird it's all just
weird
um yeah I'm still trying to think of her
name because it's not it's not Ricky
it's you guys know who I'm talking about
this is gonna drive me nuts Wow this has
never happened before you know who I
mean the girl with the glasses
okay sailor what if Polly was a spy
she's done it before and season one for
clues about Jason's death
what if she's pretending to be deep into
the farm to gain information and while
they're there if at all
it's Ethel yes this season is killing me
like obviously as bollo
because I was thinking of Evelyn yeah
where's Ethel I love you guys so much I
think we're all just in this together
how are you feeling about season three
I'm losing it okay we're gonna just read
a couple more because I still need a
film are after-show and I need to
regroup before we get to that because
this episode is nuts you guys gonna like
it I think I like it more than the Zorro
Dale which is a big compliment to
Riverdale okay one more let's see
Tatiana Williams what is alice and edgar
ship name asking for a friend so last
week i was trying to figure that out
with you guys but then i saw on twitter
that it's ever smith which I don't hate
you know Dylan with Alice has made a
name and Edgar ever and ever so ever
Smiths is apparently their schipper name
and I'm digging it and I think we're
gonna end it there thank you all so much
for tuning in to this loopy preview show
and be sure to check with me after you
watch episode 319 chapter 54 fear the
reaper for our Sweetwater secrets
after-show but first please give this
video a like hit subscribe so you never
miss it the last few episodes of
Sweetwater of the season and then hit
the comments to tell me if you can craft
my three clues
adore you all to pieces river babes and
I'll see you after the episode
[Music]
you